- [Instructor] Told the
function g is defined
over the real numbers.
This table gives a few values of g.
So for a few values of x,
they give us what g of x is equal to.
And they say what is a reasonable estimate
for the limit of g of x as x
approaches 9 from the left?
Or as x approaches nine,
remember, when we say x approaches nine
with this little superscript,
that little negative sign,
that doesn't necessarily mean
that we're approaching nine
from negative values of x.
It means that we're approaching nine
from values less than nine.
And so to think about this,
what is a reasonable
value for the left-sided,
or the left-handed limit?
We'd say, all right,
let's pick some x values
that get closer that are less than nine,
but keep getting closer
and closer to nine.
So I would look at these x values,
which they seem to have
chosen to exactly that.
They're starting at 8.9,
and they get even closer, 8.99,
then they get even closer to 8.999.
And, once again, they
only want us to figure out
whether we can estimate
the left-handed limit.
If we wanted to know the actual limit,
we would wanna figure
out the left-handed limit
and the right-handed limit
and to feel good that they seem
to be approaching the same thing.
But here we're only talking
about the left-handed.
So when I look at this at 8.9
g of x is equal to negative 5.01.
As we get even closer to
nine, we get to negative 4.83.
nine, we get to negative 4.81.
So just looking at
these three values here,
for these three x's, it looks
like we're getting close
to about negative 4.8.
So it's approximately negative 4.8.
Now we don't know that for sure.
It oftentimes a limit might
end up being a nice number
like negative 4.8, that's
not that nice of a number.
But the limit might be negative 4.8002438
that we are approaching.
It doesn't always have to go
to a nice to look at number.
But something interesting happens.
When we get exactly to nine,
all of a sudden it seems
like we get further away
from negative 4.8.
We jump to negative 5.3
So what does that tell us?
Well, this is actually trying
to tackle a key misconception
that folks have when trying
to think about limits.
A limit is the value
that you are approaching,
a value that the function is approaching
as x approaches a certain value.
It isn't necessarily going to be
what the function is
defined at that value.
So you can be approaching
a different value
than what the function is defined at.
And it looks, at least looking
at inspecting this table,
it looks like that's
what's happening here.
So what is a reasonable limit?
What is a reasonable estimate
for the left-handed limit
as x approach nine of g of x?
Well, I would rule out negative 5.3,
even though that is what g of nine is.
This is equal to g of nine.
As we approach from the left,
it does not look like we're
approaching negative 5.3.
In fact, it looks like
we're getting further
and further away.
Or it looks like we're
approaching negative 4.8.
And we're actually, as
we get closer and closer,
we're getting a little bit further
from something like negative 5.3.
So I would rule this one out.
Negative 4.8 I liked, even
before I looked at the choices
it looked like that's
what we were approaching.
So that seems like a reasonable estimate.
I like that.
So 4.7.
So 4.7, let's see,
okay, so this is tricky.
At first I was gonna say, oh, maybe.
But I realized, this isn't negative 4.7.
If it was negative 4.7,
well, maybe that would be reasonable,
we don't know for sure.
But it's not, it's 4.7.
So there's no reason why we would
be approaching negative 4.8
and then all of a sudden jump to 4.7
and that'd be the limit, that's
not what we're approaching.
We're not approaching a positive 4.7.
So definitely rule that out.
And we're definitely not approaching nine.
Here, they're just trying to confuse you.
The x is approaching nine, from the left,
from values less than nine.
But that's not what the
function itself is approaching.
The function itself seems to
be getting closer and closer
to negative 4.8.
So rule that one out.
And the limit seems to exist.
Once again, we are estimating
when we have these tables.
It's completely possible
that this is some type
of weird function that begins
to do some type of weird oscillation
as we get really close, so it oscillates
between negative 4.8 and negative 4.7.
So we don't know 100% sure.
But it's not reasonable to think,
based on this information,
that the limit doesn't exist.
So I would rule that out.
And I like this choice right over here.
Now let's do one more example.
A student created a
table to help the reason
about the limit as x
approaches three of f of x.
And so here we want the actual limits.
We want the limit as we
approach from the left
and from the right,
and see if we're
approaching the same thing.
Based on the table, what can
you reason about the limit?
So here we see x approaching,
we could say from below,
even though (laughs) visually
it looks like from above.
We're approaching x from the left.
We're approaching x from
values, we're approaching,
I should say we're
approaching three from values
to the left of three, if
we're looking at the x-axis.
So we're approaching three
from values less than three.
And it looks like, see 2.9, negative 1.28,
2.99, negative 1.42,
2.9999, negative 1.49.
So it looks like we're
getting closer and closer
to negative 1.5, negative 1.5.
And even though the function
is undefined as x equals three,
the limit could exist.
In fact, that's one of the
main values of a limit.
They say what is the function approaching
even in cases where the
function is not defined there?
So it looks like it's
approaching negative 1.5.
Now if we approach three
from the positive direction,
from values greater than three.
So we get 3.1, then our
function is negative 1.8.
3.01, our function is negative 1.63.
3.001, negative 1.51.
So even from the right,
or even from values larger than three,
it still looks like we're
approaching negative 1.5.
So this could be a reasonable estimate,
a reasonable guess based on this table
of what the limit actually is.
Now we have to be very, very careful.
You don't know definitively
just by trying out these numbers
that the limit is definitely negative 1.5.
It might be negative 1.5187 repeating.
It might be that number
We don't know for sure.
Now in a typical calculus
class in a typical exam,
you don't typically see numbers like that.
The questions are usually engineered
to give you nicer numbers.
But I just wanna make it clear.
You might be approaching
an irrational number.
You could be approaching
a pi divided by two
or something like that.
Not necessarily in this
case, but in general.
But this is a reasonable estimate.
So let's see what we can reason.
So limit x approaches three of f of x
is approximately negative 1.5.
Yeah, I think this is a reasonable thing.
So I would check that off.
Now we don't know this for sure.
In fact, there's even a scenario
where this limit still might not exist,
even if it looks like it.
Maybe as we get closer and closer
this is some type of weird function
that starts oscillating
in some strange way
or just stops getting closer
and closer to a value,
even though it looks like
it's getting closer and closer
right over here.
But this is a reasonable,
what can you reasonably reason?
I'll put that here.
What can you reasonably
reason about the limit?
There appears to be an
asymptote at x equals three.
Well, no an asymptote
would be the situation
if we were a vertical asymptote,
especially as if we seem
to be approaching infinity
or negative infinity.
And that's definitely
not the case the here.
So I'd rule that out.
As we approach x equals three,
the values of f of x seem
to approach negative 1.5.
But we can't say for sure
if that's the limit exactly.
Yeah, that's the point I
was making right over here.
It seems like it's
getting to negative 1.5.
And most questions on most
tests are kinda engineered
to give you numbers that aren't crazy.
But even with this data,
even with this information,
it might be approaching something
a little bit more interesting.
Or this could be some kinda crazy function
that as we get within
a thousandth of three,
maybe it's not defined even around three.
Maybe it's not even defined at 2.99999,
or 3.00001, or maybe it
doesn't get closer anymore.
So, once again, you don't know for sure.
But this does seem to be
a reasonable thing to say.
The values of f of x appear to oscillate,
jump back and forth,
near x equals to three,
so it's hard to say what the limit is
or if it even exists.
Well, we're not seeing that
behavior right over here.
So I wouldn't pick that.
That's not a reasonable thing,
'cause you're not
observing it in the data.
Now there are some crazy
functions out there
where all of a sudden if
you start trying out values
that are much closer than
what we're seeing here,
maybe some if this
behavior starts to happen,
but we're not seeing it in the data,
so I definitely wouldn't pick that.